vivet rang qui incite donc à une
troisième dose alors que certains
français dénoncent des effets
secondaires suite à une vaccination
complète ce soit nous donnons la parole
à ceux qui se disent sceptiques pour
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de marc boyer qui présente un
schéma vaccinal complet mais selon lui
sa femme aurait développé une maladie de
prion après la deuxième injection du
vaccin seither son témoignage au micro
des stèles farges avant de recevoir nos
invités pour en débattre justement je
suis à breuil sur verre dans l'oise je
vais rencontrer marc doyer la vie de cet
homme a changé du tout au tout il y a
quatre mois et il va nous expliquer
pourquoi bonjour marc voyer bonjour
merci beaucoup de bien vouloir témoigner
sur notre antenne alors vous votre vie a
été bouleversée début juin si vous
pouvez nous raconter pourquoi puisque
mon épouse et commencé à tomber malade
quinze jours après une injection du
vaccin files heures et entre juin et
maintenant ça c'est énormément dégradé
heureusement avec une maladie très grave
à prions où il n'y a pas de traitement
donc
à l'issue finale qui est
un décès alors à partir du moment où
votre femme est tombée malade comment
est ce que vous allez être venu à la
conclusion que c'était dû au vaccin déjà
parce que je pose la question neurologue
et je lui ai dit écoutez à ce qu' il
peut y avoir un rapport avec le vaccin
est ce genre là ils me répondent oui
peut-être on sait pas
c'est possible
mais de toute façon on verra bien s'il
ya une augmentation des cas donc c'est
quand même à la fois c'est une réponse
honnête mais c'est un petit peu entre
guillemets farfelu quand même envie
qu'on est dans un grand délire là qu'on
sait pas notre médecin traitant a
considéré que le cheminement est que au
niveau du calendrier de
de la déclaration de cette maladie pour
mon épouse il y avait quelque chose de
pas normal mon médecin traitant a fait
une déclaration
donc sur le site du ministère de la
santé je crois en déclarant que c'était
un cas suspect donc si vous voulez je
suis aujourd'hui je suis pas devant vous
comme
on risque peut-être de vouloir faire
passer ou comme un fantaisiste ou un
complotiste au quotidien je vis
une situation qui est
effroyable c'est un tortueux je souhaite
ça à personne je préfèrerais me tromper
et sincèrement me dire que mon épouse
c'est le fruit du hasard c'est devenu
quoi aujourd'hui votre quotidien au
quotidien c'est d'attendre mon épouse
décède voilà c'est terrible
c'est mon quotidien c'est d'un seul coup
je me réveille le matin
elle a un saignement née d'une et
jusqu'en bas la jouer là je me dis
qu'elle est en train de faire une
hémorragie cérébrale parce que je suis
pas médecin il est donc je lui dis mais
non ça ne laisse pas me laisse pas
tomber maintenant c'est trop tôt c'est
de surveiller voyez mon téléphone avec
une caméra parce que je peux plus sortir
même dans mon jardin parce qu'elle se
tape des crises d'angoissé effroyable et
que si je suis pas là pour la rassurer
les prises angoisse elles vont durer
pendant je sais pas combien de temps et
que l pu arracher sa perfusion qui pour
l'instant la maintient on va pas la
sauver mais lui assure un certain
confort au quotidien c'est mon fils qui
quand il voit sa mère au fond de son lit
à deux jours et demi tu sais pas pas
toutes façons maman allait presque elle
est presque déjà morte
c'est le torture
essayer d'entendre
un ministre à qui j'ai sincèrement
demander de l'aide
même pas être capable de me de me
rappeler et de continuer de tas de dire
que ce que je vis ça peut être un hasard
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression d'être seuls pour gérer
cette situation non de moins en moins
parce que je reçois énormément de
messages de soutien de témoignages de
partout même de l'étranger des antilles
et je vais vous montrer d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous avez reçu combien de
messages peu près de témoignages qui
présente de gens qui présentent les
mêmes problèmes que votre épouse alors
depuis vendredi les mêmes problèmes que
mon époux j'en ai reçu 2 je vais vous
dire celui-là qui est important je
voulais vous informer que mon frère a
été dans le même cas vacciner finder
mi-avril premiers symptômes
neurologiques semaine suivante est un
mental dégradé début mai hospitalisation
mi-mai diagnostic maladie crosstalk
jacob début juin 17 23 juin je tenais à
vous témoigner pour faire avancer la
recherche cordialement ça c'est le
premier dans quel état d'esprit est ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous ressentez est ce que c'est de la
colère est ce que c'est de la tristesse
non je sais un mélange de peine de
colère de détresse j'ai pas d'esprit de
vengeance je veux simplement con que
soit reconnue les victimes voilà parce
que je considère que les gens victimes
de vaccins on doit les considérer comme
des victimes et pas en faire des
complotistes je suis pas je veux pas me
positionner en commun et quelqu'un anti
vaccins mais je trouve que le rôle du
politique et le rôle en général de tous
ceux qui décident de notre santé c'est
avant tout nos protégés et on peut pas
simplement se contenter de dire oui mais
ça va sauver plus de gens que ça va en
tuer non parce que là on est sur des
pathologies graves avec derrière des
drames humains donc c'est pas mon job
mais c'est le leur ils ont été élus pour
ça donc maintenant c'est avait trouvé
une solution et je veux moi qui je lance
un appel là pour le coup aux députés
je trouve que les éléments que j'ai
apporté là et tout ce que j'ai collecté
ça mériterait de lancer rapidement une
enquête parlementaire voilà parce qu'on
peut pas continuer comme ça merci
beaucoup un reportage dessiné et self
âge alors que l'épidémie de covin montre
en tout cas des signes de reprise en
france comme ailleurs en europe les
hospitalisations sont en légère hausse
mais faut-il intégrer la troisième dose
au pass sanitaire alors que certains
français se montrent s'équipent sommes
nous devenus dépendants du vaccin on
attend vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france le face à face
c'est maintenant
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler philippe
froguel chercheur généticien philippe
froguel vous êtes professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2 bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous elle a ouvert sur ce
plateau sénateurs les républicains de
côte d'or bon soir là où père merci à
vous également nous accompagner ce soir
un mot philippe froguel sur ce
témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre un
certain français c'est un secret
évidemment pour personne on les entend
d'ailleurs aussi sur d'autres médias
sont sceptiques pensent que la
vaccination peut être dangereuse vous
leur répondez quoi en tant que
professeur grand défenseur du vaccin
d'abord c'est effroyable qui est à ce
qui arrive à cette famille
je ne sais pas si c'est une coïncidence
les vaccins dans une stimulation et
militaires et parfois on voit bien dans
le diabète de type 1 on a une apparition
de la maladie apparente juste après
qu'ils aient simplement a lié au fait
que ce développement immunité c'est venu
à une main il maladie qu'il toute façon
serait elle serait apparue plus tard
mais ça donne l'impression que c'est que
c'est lié je dirais simplement que healy
a possiblement mais là c'est pas du tout
prouvé des effets secondaires rarissime
de la vaccination anti léporidés c'est
absolument terrible que ça peut tomber
chez n'importe qui mais que le bénéfice
net de la vaccination est absolument
énorme et a sauvé des millions de vies
dans le monde est et las illas attenante
de gens qui font des complications des
myocardique par exemple cela a été
montré
on peut rien y faire et la même chose
dans d'autres types de vaccination et à
l'eau chaude en plein médicaments qui
sauvent des vies mais on tue
quelques-uns et l'as tous les
médicaments
ont des effets secondaires et ça c'est
dramatique jeu mais il faut considérer
le bénéfice net pour tous les autres cas
en tout cas demain doit y est on parle
d'un cas sur un million je parle sur
votre contrôle évidemment mais mais les
témoignages
voilà quand ils sont là font font mal
est-ce qu'il faut faire une enquête
parlementaire alain houpert quand vous
entendez ce type de témoignage ça vous
inspire quoi vous n'êtes pas un fan
évidemment du pass annie terre on va en
parler mais vous n'êtes pas contre le le
vaccin bien évidemment bon je voudrais
vous remercier de
passer ce reportage comme le dit le
professeur frogier c'est effroyable
c'est émouvant
l'auditeur a parlé de bénéfice risque
mais le problème dans ce bénéfice risque
on ne parle jamais du risque et en
médecine
puisque nous sommes tous les deux
médecins cher cher confrère
on a été éduqué par le par le doute et
de bénéfice du doute il est important
pour progresser
l'écouté des gens et quand on regarde
les donner
quand on regarde les données européennes
de files heures il ya un demi million de
complications avec ce vaccin dès crav
dénombrable des bénigne mais il faut le
prendre en compte pour progresser dans
la vaccination est la problématique
c'est que
reparler du passé ni terre évidemment je
suis contre lopez sanitaire et être
contre le passé ni terre c'est remettre
en cause la politique vaccinale du
gouvernement
et tant que l'on n'aura pas remis en
cause ces politiques vaccinales on ne
pourra jamais parler des effets
secondaires du vaccin au risque d'être
comédie ou dieter un complotiste je
crois qu'il faut relever la tête se met
tout son sens arrêtez de diviser la
france entre ceux qui sont pour entre
ceux qui sont contre ce que la france
est divisée la france elle est dans une
crise épidémique mais dans une crise
sociale psychologique grave il faut se
remettre tous ensemble et puis
travailler réfléchir évidemment il faut
une commission pour les commissions
c'est pas là pour enterrer les choses ça
doit être là pour progresser
une commission fait de professionnels de
parce qu'il ya une commission sur le
comité j'ai regardé la liste des gens
qui est invité on a invité des préfets
des ars quelques médecins peu de
chercheurs le chercheur qui savent ce
que c'est qu'une molécule qui savent ce
que c'est qu'un chromosomes
je crois qu'il faut progresser on
il faut s'obstiner à chercher toujours
cherché à laon père souligne voilà le
fait qu'en france on parle peut-être pas
assez d des risques et ce qui ouvre
peut-être justement la porte à des à des
théories parfois
conspirationnistes il est sain justement
d'en parler peut-être parce que vous
l'avez dit vous-même il existe parfois
des risques comme sur tous les vaccins
et surtout de les expliquer
il faut bien entendu parler et dire la
vérité aux gens et le fait que depuis le
début de l'épidémie et pouvoirs publics
en ont ils des discours pour le moins
variable exemple sur le masque à ça
entraîne le que le public à peu
confiance
la troisième dose moi je suis à fond
pour la troisième le rouge on a montré
en israël comme quoi c'était efficace
pour combattre le variant delta mais je
comprends très bien que beaucoup de gens
ne le fasse pas on leur a vanté que le
vaccin c'est l arme absolue est donc ce
n'est pas l'absolu c'est une arme très
efficace mais certainement pas absolue
et si on avait expliqué aux gens à la
vérité qu'on connaissait peut-être pas
mais qu'on aille pas fait semblant de
croire que tout était géniale et bien
les gens n'aurais pas cru que de toute
façon c'était fini cela peut se faire
cette troisième dose que je veux dire
c'est que dire la vérité au public en
tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est toujours la
meilleure solution parce qu'à long terme
c'est ce qui est le plus efficace et je
suis pas du tout sûr qu'on ait fait ça
depuis un an et demi et c'est ce qu'on
fait en tout cas ce soir on va faire un
point sur l'épidémie en tout cas de co
vite car les indicateurs clignotent en
regarder tu as l'air de covin tracker
sur les réseaux sociaux
élément confirmant une hausse de
l'activité épidémique les formes graves
sont de nouveau en hausse depuis une
semaine 220 admission chaque jour à
l'hôpital + 14% en une semaine cinquante
et une admission chaque jour en soins
critiques + 12 % en une semaine on avait
regardé dans le prolongement la croupe
qu'il publié près donc une longue
descente et bien on voit qu'elle est en
phase ascendante on va donc peut-être
avoir une cinquième vague cet hiver on
souhaite pas mais mais c'est la crainte
d'alain houpert c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement veut prolonger le passé ni
terre jusqu'en juillet inciter à la
vaccination ce n'est pas nécessaire de
vendre ces chiffres on a parlé de
premier league les deux premières
de premières vagues qui était une valve
de mortel parce que on a refusé tout
traitement on a laissé les gens chez jeu
avec lui doliprane alors qu'on aurait pu
ne serait-ce que les assistés arrêt
respiratoire mans l'ordonné
d'anticoagulants leur donner des
corticoïdes ensuite il ya eu la seconde
la troisième et la quatrième c'est une
vague une vague mathématique puisque
elle a été créée par suite au discours
du président de la république où les
gens sont allés se faire tester et on a
vu qu'on avait des gens qui étaient
positifs mais non au malade
donc j'ai peur dans dans les discours du
gouvernement et quand je voit
l'acharnement du gouvernement à
convaincre les gens c'est qu'il ya un
problème
il faut raison garder et si le vaccin
marchait si bien on n'aurait pas besoin
de troisième dose et
et le vaccin dire que le vaccin est le
seul la seule issue
pour une épidémie
jamais appris ça en médecine parce que
sinon la grippe ne tuerait pas quinze
mille personnes
parents et
ne qu'on n'aurait pas admis 2002
millions
5,2 contaminés par an et puis
la grippe serait qu'un souvenir je pense
que cette année nous aurons peut-être
plus de morts de la grippe que du co
lead donc je pense que je dénonce c'est
le discours alarmiste du gouvernement
qui affole les gens les gens ils ont
peur c'est le discours de la peur
philippe froguel quand elle a ouvert
vous dis c'est peut-être que le vaccin
n'est pas assez efficace c'est peut-être
aussi pour aller plus loin que le vaccin
n'est pas efficace assez longtemps
que maintenant que pour les personnes
qui ont été vaccinées en janvier et qui
ont plus de 60 70 ans ou un certain
nombre de ces gens il ya une baisse de
l'immunité c'est pour ça que la
troisième dose a été fait qui est très
efficace en israël israël a une une
vague énorme à malgré la vaccination
ils ont revacciner une grande partie de
la population d'âge moyen et élevé et là
maintenant et il ya une diminution très
importante des cas et des cas graves
donc oui ces vaccins
sont c'est comme vaccin pour la grippe 1
ça dure ça doit pas très longtemps est
un des problèmes heureusement on peut le
refaire et on peut espérer dans ce cas
là on restera ces chiffres relativement
bas de nouveaux caïds nous n'avons il
part hospitalisés et pas de garantie
complètement c'est pour ça que moi je
suis pour le passé ni terra et surtout
je suis pour l'ibpt et gestes barrières
notamment les masques en intérieur pour
éviter que ce virus très contagieux se
passe d'une personne à l'autre même
vacciné avec un risque quand même qu'on
soit un mois je connais des gens qui ont
été à
vacciner et se sont payé
encore à un épisode de koh vide au
cinéma il ya quelques semaines
personnes portaient le masque sont
restées 2h30 avoir avoir un film
donc les aérosols sont emprunts à
risques deux sont faire
atteindre à nouveau par par la maladie
ce sim parfois malgré la vaccination
dont il n'y a pas de mesure miracle
pardonnez moi ça veut dire que pour
revenir à la question de départ de ce
débat ça veut dire concrètement que nous
sommes devenus dépendants au vaccin et
il va falloir renouveler tous les six
mois des doses vous n'avez pas porter
français se lassent
et entendu qu'ils vont se lasser ils se
sont déjà là c'est d'ailleurs puisque on
a le pouvoir ne manqua pas fait
d'ailleurs une grande campagne a pour ça
n'a pas réussi à atteindre ses objectifs
de revalidation des personnes âgées on a
une sorte de course de vitesse
aujourd'hui à on espère qu'après cet
hiver qu'il faut pas qu'il faudra passer
de toute façon lave la pandémie va
atteindre il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
véritablement de variants très dangereux
le delta plus ça n'arrive pas à percer
parce qu'il est finalement pas plus
contagieux que le delta
il faut à faire ce que nous pouvons de
manière modeste mais déterminée pour
passer l'hiver est à espérer que au
printemps prochain la pandémie terminera
et se terminent toujours cet essai
pandémie mais la question à se poser
c'est combien de personnes vont mourir
d'ici là combien on va faire l'écho
bilan et c'est celle-là il faut
l'essayer d'agir le mieux possible
les français sont levés dépendant de
belles paroles et des craintes en 8 par
ce gouvernement c'est un message que
vient de mon post et david sur d'autres
concertée télégramme vous êtes
évidemment d'accord avec ce postulat
vous nous le disiez il n'empêche elle a
ouvert aujourd'hui le pdg de modern à
stéphane bancel nous dit selon moi il
faut vacciner les jeunes enfants si on
regarde ce qu'il s'est passé aux états
unis où il a eu beaucoup plus de cas de
delta qu'en france presque 20 % des
américains hospitalisés étaient des
enfants ce qui n'était pas du tout le
cas avec la souche originel que vous
inspire cette sortie c'est surprenant
c'est surprenant de voir dans le
parisien
un journal qui appartient à une des plus
grandes fortunes de france
qui elle aussi a investi en 2016
l'entreprise moderna de voir ne
serait-ce pas au delà de l'article de
voir un chapeau ou le pdg stéphane
bancel moderna conseille la vaccination
aux enfants
modern a engrangé plus de 2 milliards
d'euros de fortune personnelle monsieur
vencel c'est c'est l'équivalent d'une
campagne de vaccination complète d'un
pays comme la france
la position de stéphane bancel c'est la
position d'un investisseur c'est pas la
position d'un médecin j'aurais aimé le
parisien
interview un médecin thériault le
professeur froguel et quand le maître
quant au vaccin ne révèle de vraies
actions nouvelles ne relève plus du
commerce quand il devient obligatoire
et les profits je suis un je suis un
libéral mais là ya une obligation
les profits devraient être au service de
la recherche et je suis d'accord avec le
professeur fogiel et à l'âge d'or sur
certains points d'accord sur
le fait qu'il a dit qu' il ya une
urgence
d'accélérer séquençage des variantes
pour éviter de se faire déborder par la
maladie et il faut que la technocratie
laisse la place à la médecine
il faut s'engager dans la recherche de
traitements et arrêter de croire que le
vaccin est la seule solution et je suis
heureux dans cette cacophonie entre
scientifiques que mon confrère être
adopté une position honnête et impartial
monsieur le professeur frau gel et
contre le professeur raoul tu es il n'a
pas été agressif et indécent ce qui leur
a valu dans les réseaux sociaux des
attaques des gens qui étaient pro bac
saint des attaques excessives et voilà
je j'apprécie sa neutralité je suis
d'accord avec lui mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui sur combler les trous
vaccinale on va lui poser la question
justement philippe froguel assure cette
sortie de de stéphane bancel inquiets on
va pas se mentir peut inquiéter chaque
parent qui nous dit presque 20% des
amériques et hospitalisées étaient des
enfants philippe froguel maintenant le
virus et et dangereux aussi pour les
enfants on nous dit constamment le
contraire qui croire
la situation américaine et pas celle de
la france beaucoup d'enfants sont très
obèses
aux etats unis beaucoup viennent de
minorités qui sont à un plus grand
risque de
le faire dès des formes graves et nous
on n'a pas 20 % d'adp enfance dans les
hôpitaux un rapport aux adultes danse
cette situation américaine n'est pas la
situation française moi je n'ai aucune
religion concernant la vaccination des
enfants de cinq ans j'aurais tendance à
penser qu' il faut attendre un peu et
voir ce qui se passe
surtout protéger les grands parents
c'est pour ça que moi je suis pour la
revaccination des grands parents parce
que c'est eux qui sont en contact avec
les enfants autre part que des jeunes se
fassent la maladie ça arrive en
angleterre il y en avait à peu près 80%
des quarante mille par jour
mais garde relativement peu d'adultes
aujourd'hui qui meurt donc faut toujours
penser à l'intérêt de faire les choses a
bénéfi ce risque moi je pense pas que ce
soit dangereux pour les enfants mais et
peut-être dangereux pour la paix sauf
que faire ce qu'on peut avec les armes
actuelles avant de de penser avoir de
nouvelles armes et je suis bien d'accord
sur une chose il n'ya pas de la
vaccination il ya les gestes barrières
les traitements pour l'instant on n'a
pas été efficace là dessus nous à
l'institut pasteur de lille en test à un
traitement avec beaucoup de retard parce
que on nous a empêché de le faire depuis
neuf mois mais maintenant ça a commencé
et très compliqué une pandémie nouvelle
on a fait beaucoup de choses mais à une
certain nombre de bêtises et on s'est
beaucoup disputé alors qu'on n'aurait
pas dû je pense simplement que il faut
analyser sereinement la situation et et
au jour le jour cette question ne pas
sanitaire jusqu'en juin
personnellement je serais plutôt
d'accord de le faire que jeu jusqu'en
février comme le propose le sénat a et
de revoir après si on veut changer ce
n'est que politique merci beaucoup
philippe afghane merci alain houpert
d'avoir été avec mon source au plateau
juste